this is no ordinary crime scene
behind the cordon yellow plaques
numbered from one to six are all that
distinguished the remains of one life
from another each body burnt beyond
recognition
like so many victims in the town of
butcher their identities are not yet
known
but what is clear is ukraine's resolve
for
[Music]
how can you talk to vladimir putin when
his forces do this
go to hell
[Applause]
a sentiment also felt keenly by the body
collectors of butcher
their van arrived already loaded
the police chief says some 1200 war
crimes have been registered so far
across the whole region
area
of
[Music]
the destruction in this town stands
testimony to the trauma unleashed when
russian troops invaded
their withdrawal a few days ago means
investigators can more freely gather
eyewitness statements fingerprints and
video evidence
but living with such death is almost too
much for the remaining residents to bear
who do you blame for this
is
we've not been here very long but in
this small corner of butcher we've
already counted eight bodies there are
many more houses and gardens yet to be
searched ukrainians say that every death
is going to be investigated and cases
built so that prosecutions for war
crimes can be heard
down the road three more stolen lives
discarded in death
but further evidence for ukraine's
investigators
their goal is justice so the victims of
russia's war can finally rest in peace
debrahing sky news butcher